now that the president is in orange the
economy's
in great shape that is the unified
message from basically everyone the new
york times the chairman of the
federal reserve told us that the other
day with joe biden in office things are
about to explode
in a good way and we certainly hope
that's true of course
but how are people doing right now well
one way to measure that probably the way
that matters most
is what does it cost to buy things the
things that you need
is inflation real are you paying more
for gas for example or groceries than
you were a year ago how about a month
ago
well we can measure that in a real way
according to the bureau of labor
statistics consumer prices rose in march
at the fastest pace in nine years
the new york times told us don't be
misled it's not real inflation's not
real but here are the numbers
gasoline prices rose over nine percent
in a single month
depending on where you live gas may have
risen even more in washington dc
for example the average price of gas
last year was
and sixteen cents a gallon right now
it's over three bucks a gallon
that's 40 percent in one year
and it's not just gas oil markets are
obviously very complex
everything has gotten more expensive
pretty much the price of eggs increased
increased by almost five percent
major appliances by almost 15 percent
fresh fruit 5.6 percent
ground beef five and a half percent
propane kerosene firewood
16 to heat your house also up 16
is the median sales price of existing
homes in some places it's up
hundreds of percent there's also been a
massive increase in the selling prices
from domestic production of goods
things like softwood lumber that
increased by
83.2 percent compared to this time last
year 83
for dimensional lumber softwood spruce
two by fours
what are we out of trees we might be ply
would increase by 53 percent
so the question is what does this mean
for you well did your income go up 83
last year probably not
it means you have a lot less money your
costs increase
your income doesn't it becomes much more
expensive to live but again according to
new york times
don't worry about it one of their
headlines recently
warned readers to quote not get fooled
by the new inflation numbers because
that's what looking
backward it's inflation nonsense it'll
disappear after the pandemic
again we hope that's true other news
outlets are bold enough to admit yes
there's inflation but not because of joe
biden
or his spending trillions of dollars per
bill no you know what it is
it's climate change it's climate change
just doing it
so either inflation isn't real and
you're a right-wing kook for thinking it
is nine dollars for a two by four it's
always been nine dollars
or it tells you you don't believe in
climate change or it tells you just
shut up and obey and that tells you
everything their response
again nothing to see here we hope
they're right